how are you guys doing
good how you doing love your office i
know totally look at the gotcha moving
back there
love it yeah if you want to introduce
them in a future episode of what if
meets you know the mcu meets got your
man i would freak the f
out i would love that i legally i have
no idea but yes
yeah that would be amazing uh first let
me start with congratulations on the
first three episodes
uh they're fantastic cannot wait to see
the rest
um did you guys ever pitch to like
disney though and by the way maybe this
is a season two or season four thing
but like what if a marvel character
entered another
disney franchise for example like trump
you know like
the combination of the disney worlds
i would if i was kind of notorious for
trying to get the star wars character
involved
and we did try at one point but there
was just
it's kind of like play with the sandbox
you were given we gave you the entire
mcu run with that and i was like okay
but still
luke skywalker would be an amazing jedi
he's an amazing avenger
he's a cheddar and we did have those
thoughts and we were just like
and then that's when they're like hey
guys guys a little bit of guidelines
sorry
maybe maybe the mcu let's stick with so
it's true but we were thinking about
them who knows if fans watch it love it
and clamor enough
if future episodes who who knows what
can happen you know what if right
yeah listen by the way multiverse what
if i mean you mix these
all these realities uh because i know
mark hamill i mean if you
you got you know what i mean he likes
doing voices of course
totally are you kidding it'd be amazing
yes
yes also the other thing is that what if
uh
opens the door for consumer products at
disney to sell all this alt
merchandise so you figure maybe that's
the way in is going after consumer
products and saying look how many star
wars toys sell
in the marvel toys let's get luke
skywalker in here because think about
the sales oh yeah i think you should be
putting together the business pitch for
this
this [ __ ] works just it's true the money
you know not the story it's the money
you guys can make
by letting us do this that's true dude
it's true no we've
there's a bunch of ideas that we're put
around
and who knows maybe at some point maybe
we'll get lucky and get to
go further but first order of business
was like
let's open up the multiverse off the
films that we know
and then we hopefully as things progress
things can get wilder
wilder and more crazy so yeah season 20
baby groot and baby yoda can have a play
date
exactly have a play date that's adorable
it's adorable
everything about that is great um i i am
curious from because
i know it's going to be a hit people are
going to dig this thing and i know
season 2 is coming next year or the year
after
if if they say okay we want you guys to
make another season
what now that you have the
infrastructure figured out how long
would it take
to start writing and get like a season
three on the air
well i guess it depends on a number of
things you know i mean it's like
sometimes vendors change and then they
have to like get up to speed
that can slow things down so um trying
to get it done in a year's time can
can be tough uh but not not impossible
so
i mean who knows it really depends on
what they have planned for us
moving forward and how the audience
response is to these i mean
we know it's we think it's gonna be
great we think it's gonna be big and
people aren't doing it
you never know until you know so
do you see will any episodes that from
season one
have a continuation in season two or is
every what if like a self-contained
thing
well the fun of what if is that it's an
anthology series
so we're able to take each episode and
play pretty hardcore with genre and tone
we get to do a heist episode we get to
do our tragic romance we get to do
i mean our thriller the idea
beyond that anything is possible what
they like to say around the marvel
building
so our lips are sealed when it comes to
the future
you guys have to wait wait and see wait
and see
got it um so is it too can you tease if
i'm curious for example if season one
ends on a finale
where you need to watch season two or
you know what i mean like if these are
all
really self-contained oh i see i see
well i mean there is a lot of
self-containment
uh otherwise i know you have to watch
the episodes
i don't know you know the way i work i'm
collider come on these are the questions
i'm going to be asking
you know i'm digging um you know what i
mean
but for you guys it must be interesting
behind the scenes making a series like
this
what do you think might surprise fans to
learn about the making of what if
i think the biggest surprise for people
who don't know animation is that
i always joke it's a medium of patience
how long one of these episodes
take to make and we started working on
this in 2018
and actually most of my work on season
two is actually already
kind of done and but i like the fans
have to wait another
x many years to see the work um
so i think that usually surprises people
more than anything
i hope the audience is surprised by the
amount of easter eggs and cameos
that we jam-packed both into the script
and in with brian's directing kind of
alluding to everything in the movies in
the comic books
my hope is that collider maybe every uh
thursday puts out here's all the easter
eggs you missed in this episode
our articles cause trust me there's
gonna be loads
yeah actually i have to wrap but that
actually brings up an excellent point
which is i've seen the first three and
i'm going to watch them again when
when i they're in high quality on disney
plus but are there a lot of
like single frames or moments that you
want to hit pause on
because you will be like oh my god i
think so
i think whether it's an easter egg or
something of that nature i think
you might want to pause just because
there's some images that pop up that the
team
just knocked out of the park and they
just look so beautiful they're just like
click
that's cool you know what i mean so i
think there's gonna be stuff
we keep joking it's like there's i think
there's a lot of meme worthy things
going on in the show
and and gifts that people can pull and
do all kinds of stuff with
um so yeah i think so i think i think
there will be some yes to that question
for sure
cannot wait to i gotta go i can't wait
to watch the rest of the episodes and
hope to talk to you guys more
more spoilery uh down the road indeed
please do yeah
when marvel security isn't breathing
down our necks
thank you have a great day